haha the Joe Rogan experience watchin TV
this happened a couple weeks ago and I
started laughing because all that popped
into my head was you when they released
the footage of those UFOs talk about
this the next day I'm so happy I love it
but wasn't that released like a year ago
well it was leaked the Pentagon finally
looked in the middle of the pandemic
what a great time to just admit there's
UFOs because I'm one of the things that
I said on my Instagram I was like in any
other time in history
if the government came out and said
there are flying saucers that defy our
understanding of propulsion and physics
the world will go crazy but in 2020
people like ya there's nothing that has
anybody seen those pilots well I've had
one of them on here oh so he doesn't
believe it yeah dr. commander David
flavor I had him on the podcast and he
was explaining the whole thing to me
like his experience off the coast of San
Diego running into one of these things I
mean there's people that are debunkers
then they need to understand this is not
just visual they they had very specific
like actual real data including radar
they tracked these things they use
sophisticated military tracking these
are real objects this is not like
there's a lot of dummies out there that
want debunk everything mm-hmm and
they're just as much of a religious
person as someone who's a true believer
they're a true believer that everything
can be explained
well not everything can be explained and
these things can't be explained when
when they're explaining how these things
traveled at these ProPublica they went
from like 6 feet off the ground a 60,000
feet in a matter of a couple of seconds
they fly in some way that these military
aircraft pilots can't explain they don't
understand it and they don't know what
they are now whether they're from
another planet that's never been proven
they might be interdimensional they
might be something from here they might
be some super sophisticated top of the
food chain top-secret stuff that they're
exposing these people to just so they
freak out and like let's let's see if
they
can get a you know get an explanation
for this
let's let's launch these things and have
them fly past people at these
preposterous rates of speed and see what
the reaction is do you think knows those
types of secrets if there are are higher
than the president do you really do you
think there's an organization that's
above president 100% ninety percent
here's why presidents come and go yeah
I'm every four years we're gonna trust
some [ __ ] who wins a popularity
contest Trump's a perfect example of
that here's the guy who's not even a
politician lifelong businessman who wins
a popularity contest gets to be in the
most powerful office most powerful
position really the world's ever known
president United States
commander-in-chief of the greatest army
this entire planet has ever seen you
gonna tell him
[Applause]